Deb's   back,   and   she's   got   a   fresh
cup   of   coffee   ready   to   take   it
into   the   AM.
In   case   you   didn't   know   it,   you're
tuned   into   the   Deb   of   Night   on
KTRK.
I'm   your   lovely   hostess.
Feel   free   to   fantasize   about   me   all
you   want,   but   please   don't   send   any
more   drawings.
The   lines   are   all   full,   so   why
don't   I   provide   some   release?
Line   three,   you're   speaking   to   me.
'Sup,   Deb?
And   what   have   you   been   up   to
tonight,   caller?
Wink,   wink.
[laughs]   I'm   getting,   uh,   [laughs]   I'm   messed
up,   Deb.
Whoo.
What's   the   occasion?
It's   a   weekday.
Touche.
Hey,   Deb.
[laughs]   Hey,   Deb.
Yes,   general?
Oh,   bad.
I   had   this   amazing   idea.
I,   uh,   you   ready   for   this?
All   night.
Y-   you   know   all   those   problems   we've
been   having   in   the   Mid   East?
Yes,   those   damn   Virginians.
Okay,   okay.
So   like   I   figured   this   out,   right?
Okay,   okay,   so   if   we   want   peace
in   the   Mid   East,   think   about   it.
What   makes   people   peaceful?
Smoking   this   sensimilla.
And   what   brings   people   together?
Pizza.
So   like   think   on   this.
For   like   half   the   cost   of   one
of   those,   um,   blockbuster   bombs,   we,   we
could   like   buy   enough   pizza   and   enough
herb   for   like   everybody   over   there.
And   then   like   bam,   instant   best   buds,
man.
Just   say   no,   dude.
Um,   and   extra   pepperoni.
Hey,   you   guys   take   credit   cards?
Moving   on.
Line   four,   what's   keeping   you   up   tonight?
Deb,   I'm   about   to   reveal   something   that,
I'm   putting   my   life   on   the   line,
but   the   people,   the   people   of   this
city   and   this   country   and   this   planet,
they   have   the   right   to   know   this.
Do   you   understand?
What's   the   word,   Gomez?
This   is   serious.
There   are   a   lot   of   organizations   that
would   do   anything   in   their   power   to
keep   this   a   secret.
I   don't   doubt.
Deb,   Deb,   this   is   really   serious   now.
Can   I   finish?
All   right.
Everyone   knows   they've   got   cameras   at   every
stoplight   so   th-   the   government   can   keep
tabs   on   our   comings   and   goings.
But   did   you   know   that   they   then
sell   access   to   their   databases   to   the
Illuminati,   who   has   been   using   that   information
to   compile   a   list   of   the   most
frequently   traveled   routes,   and   then   opening   new
locations   of   their   well-known   chain   of   coffee
houses   in   the   most   profitable   locations?
And   did   you   also   know   that   they
use   those   funds   to   suppress   fusion   and
solar   power?
It   all   makes   sense   now.
Well,   they,   the   Illuminati,   control   all   the
world's   energy,   and   because   they   monitor   all
of   our   energy   usage,   they   can   tell
who   is   not   watching   television,   and   therefore
know   who   is   not   receiving   the   subliminal
messages   that   they   send   to   keep   the
sheep   putting   their   money   in   banks   and
away   from   their   secret   headquarters,   AKA   Wyoming.
Amazing.
Anything   else   that   you've   turned   up   lately?
As   a   matter   of   fact,   and   again,
I   shouldn't   be   talking   about   this,   but
I   believe   it   is   everybody's   right   to
know   that   recycling   is   a   myth.
All   they   do   with   those   bottles   and
cans   is   collect   DNA   samples   from   your
saliva   so   that   they   can   clone   you
and   train   your   clone   to   assassinate   you
and   assume   your   identity   should   you   go
poking   your   nose   into   the   whole   global
warming   business.
Thank   you,   Gomez.
I   hate   to   interrupt   this   mentally   stimulating
conversation,   but   the   people   who   keep   me
chained   to   the   console   at   this   radio
station,   in   my   underwear   no   less,   want
you   to   spend   money   on   this   stuff.
Last   year,   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   bought
a   sports   utility   vehicle.
Three   months   later,   there   were   two   separate
incidences   of   hit   and   runs   by   an
unidentified   SUV   in   his   area.
Is   Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   to   blame?
Can   you   afford   to   take   that   chance?
Can   your   children?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   a   candidate
that   has   never   committed   vehicular   homicide.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   has   never   publicly
stated   his   opinion   on   child   pornography.
Is   it   because   he's   hiding   something?
Would   you   want   a   child   pornographer   voting
on   this   nation's   laws?
Would   you   trust   your   children's   future   to
someone   like   that?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   the   candidate
that   is   committed   to   locking   up   child
pornographers.
Democratic   candidate   Michael   Rebens   recently   sued   Senator
Robert   Thorn   for   accusing   Rebens   of   being
a   murderous   child   pornographer,   but   Rebens   had
previously   said   he   was   against   clogging   up
courts   with   frivolous   lawsuits.
Wouldn't   this   make   him   a   hypocrite?
Would   you   want   a   hypocrite   as   your
next   congressman?
Would   you   want   your   children   to   become
hypocrites?
Vote   Republican   Senator   Robert   Thorn,   a   candidate
not   accused   of   being   a   murderous   child
pornographer.
Preparing   for   a   business   sales   pitch   but
don't   know   how   to   sell   your   ideas?
Try   Virtual   Meeting.
So   if   we   divert   advertising   away   from
expensive   television   spots   and   spread   it   around
full-page   ads   in   the   leading   men's   magazines,
we   can-   That's   an   idea,   but   here
is   what   I   think   we   should   do.
But   I   didn't   finish.
Yes,   that's   a   good   point,   but   everyone
listen   to   my   idea.
But   I   think-   That's   true.
However,   I   don't   think   that   our   target
market   will   be   willing   to   accept   such
a   radical   approach.
Listen   to   what   I   have   to   say
on   the   subject.
Are   you   ready?
Good.
This   is   a   winner.
And   Virtual   Meeting   doesn't   just   help   with
meetings.
It   can   also   prepare   you   for   debating
your   ideas   on   the   internet.
So   I   think   if   the   Democrats   are
going   to   have   a   chance   at   the
office,   they   are   going   to   have   to
embrace   the   more   liberal   sect   of   the
voter   block.
Shut   up,   [beep]   tard.
I   majored   in   political   science.
I   think   I   know   what   I'm   talking
about   here.
Laughing   out   loud.
You   are   so   gay.
Virtual   Meeting,   the   only   meeting   preparation   device
to   own.
That   was   a   good   idea,   which   was
mine   originally,   [beep]   tard.
In   1984,   a   generation   of   children   were
introduced   to   a   toy   that   became   an
instant   classic.
20   years   later,   that   toy   is   transforming
to   blend   into   a   whole   new   environment.
Hey,   Bob,   right?
Mind   if   I   borrow   your   stapler?
You   want   staples?
Get   some   of   these,   Executron.
Ah.
Take   control   of   the   noble   Officebots   as
they   wage   slave   their   secret   war   against
the   evil   Executrons.
Hey,   I'm   gonna   be   here   pretty   late.
Do   you   mind   if   I   get   a
cup   of   that   coffee?
Grafatron,   transform.
Coffee   is   for   closers,   Officebot.
Collect   30   different   corporate   robots   as   they
battle   for   workplace   supremacy.
Look   out,   Optical   Mouse   Prime,   it's   Cell
Owner.
I've   got   your   number,   employees,   and   you're
all   getting   called   in   this   weekend.
Officebots,   transform   and   clock   in.
Deformers.
You   live.
You   die.
And   sometimes   you   get   brought   back   to
life.
This   fall.
I'm   afraid.
I   can't   see   too   well   these   days.
Do   you   think   you   could   go   to
the   nearest   village   and   pick   me   up
a   loaf   of   bread?
Bread,   good.
The   new   horror   RPG   from   Troika   Games.
Bread.
Oh,   I   can   tell   you   where   the
bakery   is,   stranger,   but   before   I   do,
would   you   mind   picking   up   my   little
girl   from   the   lake?
You   are   the   monster.
Or   are   you?
If   you   wanna   enter   this   bakery,   you'll
have   to   defeat   me,   and   this   torch.
Frankenstein   Breadlust,   coming   soon   to   a   PC
near   you.
Game,   good